it's been about six months since apple
released their new macbook pros and i've
not only been putting them through a lot
of testing here in the office but also
at home because i finally upgraded from
my old 2018 intel 15 inch model to the
new 16 inch m1 max macbook pro and i
definitely have some thoughts after six
months to say the least and now that we
finally released our one month review of
apple's new mac studio i can now give
you guys my thoughts on which machine is
the better buy the macbook or the studio
but first i wanted to share my at-home
experience with my new 16-inch macbook
pro so let's jump right into that first
of all one of the biggest advantages i
noticed going from my old 15-inch intel
model was the increase in battery life
since i'm now finally able to use it for
multiple sessions without having to plug
it in and my absolute favorite new
feature is the new display because it
has multiple advantages over previous
macbook displays like the fact that it
comes with the super slim bezels because
that's something i notice every time i
use it and after six months the notch
has literally had zero negative impact
on my experience i barely even notice it
anymore but the main game changer for
everyday use has been the 120 hertz pro
motion display because now that it's
been six months chrome and safari now
properly support 120hz browsing and
everything just feels so smooth and
responsive because of it perfectly
matching my 120hz experience on my
iphone and not even looking at promotion
the web browsing itself is super snappy
compared to old intel max because of the
m1 max chip having really high single
core performance so there are no
stutters or issues whatsoever especially
thanks to the super fast 32 gigs of
unified memory and the equally fast
built-in ssds i also basically never
hear the fans on this new macbook pro
which is an awesome change compared to
my old intel macbook pro which would
sometimes spin up the fans while even
just browsing the web now another one of
my favorite features on the new macbook
pro is the absolutely incredible speaker
system that has graduated from laptop's
speaker level to sound like an actual
set of dedicated desktop speakers now in
terms of performance i honestly think i
went a bit overkill by going with the 32
core m1 max chip because i don't think
i've gotten even close to maxing it out
in my workloads for example i often use
my macbook to create thumbnails at home
when we're falling a bit behind at the
office and it has absolutely zero issues
in photoshop and i also did a bit of
video editing and i haven't ever felt
like my mind is working faster than this
macbook pro so the performance is great
now the reason i got the 32 core m1 max
model was first of all for future
proofing and second of all because i
wanted to make sure i had the absolute
most graphics performance for gaming to
try and take advantage of the 120 hertz
display but now that i'm a father of two
i don't really play that often anymore
so i honestly think i would have been
completely fine with the base m1 pro
chip because it's enough to handle
everything i'm currently doing on it so
my experience after six months has been
absolutely amazing and it's the happiest
i've ever been with a single mac product
except for one issue
the mini led display
yes the new display can reach up to 1600
nits of brightness while viewing or
editing hdr content which is awesome but
when you're using it normally like when
you're browsing the web is limited to
just the standard 500 nits but with the
new vivid app for mac you can get the
brightness up to 1 000 nits all the time
which is super useful for outdoor use or
any bright environment and know they're
not sponsoring this video now my main
issue with the mini led display is
blooming where you can see a glow behind
bright objects on the display especially
in the dark now while you're looking
directly at the display you can't really
notice it but the blooming problem
became annoying to me when i watched the
movie dune with my wife while on the
couch and i was looking at the display
from the side and that's where blooming
problems became really apparent but
other than that the mini led display has
been great so overall my six month
experience with my new 16-inch macbook
pro has been awesome but now let's
switch over to a more high performance
oriented outlook and compare it to the
new max studio which can now be packed
with the m1 ultra chip being the main
advantage over the macbook pro first of
all the base price of the mac studio for
only 2 000 is very impressive because it
comes with the m1 max chip built in
which is exactly how much it costs for
the cheapest m1 pro chip in the 14 inch
macbook pro but to make the comparison
as fair as possible between the mac
studio and the more expensive 16 inch
macbook pro we configured both of them
with exactly the same specs and the
macbook pro ends up being eleven hundred
dollars more expensive than the mac
studio however you also have to factor
in the fact that you'll still need to
buy a mouse a keyboard and a display for
the mac studio which could get expensive
very quickly if you decide to go for
apple's own magic accessories and new
studio display which together come out
to around nineteen hundred dollars but
just to give the max studio the benefit
of the doubt let's give it a much less
expensive display like the 27 inch asus
pro art 4k display that of course
doesn't match up in terms of the refresh
rate but it's still a good option and
then we'll add in another 100
for a basic mouse and keyboard and now
with those changes the macbook pro is
only 500 more expensive than this mac
studio setup 3100 instead of 2600 so
let's get into the performance
comparison we tested various workflows
and apps from all kinds of benchmarks
like cinebench r23 graphics tests like
gfx bench and a lot of real world tests
like xcode photo editing in adobe
lightroom classic and various video
editing tests and to our surprise the
macbook pro actually beat out the mac
studio in a bunch of different tests
which didn't make any sense at all so
it's pretty clear that apple is not
allowing the m1 max max studio to
perform even an ounce better than the m1
max macbook pro even though it's a
desktop which is extremely disappointing
so with that said paying 500 more for
the macbook pro setup actually seems
like a much better value because you can
actually take it on the go wherever you
want which is a massive value add
compared to the mac studio which
absolutely must be connected to the wall
now of course the biggest downside of
the macbook pro is that you can't get
the m1 ultra chip which is currently
only available in the mac studio and
it's now the main reason so many people
are thinking about buying the mac studio
so here are the specs of the machines
we're comparing with the 4 000 max
studio with a binned 48 core gpu and 64
gigs of ram and by adding in the 600
accessories it is now 1100
more expensive than the higher end 32
core gpu m1 max macbook pro with 32 gigs
of ram now the first point i want to
make is that everyday performance for
common things like web browsing barely
improves by two percent because basic
tasks are based on single core
performance which doesn't really change
much between the m1 max and the ultra
now multi-core performance is where the
ultra shines because you're getting 91
more power for 31 more cash which is a
great investment but translating that to
real world performance the xcode
programming benchmark was only 22 faster
because the m1 max was already
incredibly fast due to the unified
memory architecture so it's not really
worth it for programmers but the real
winner in terms of performance was
exporting photos in lightroom classic
where the ultra was almost twice as fast
making the extra 1100 very worth it but
in terms of actual editing smoothness
the m1 max was already perfect for us
now we ended up creating a panorama
using lightroom and here the ultra was
only 23 faster so it wasn't really worth
it now moving over to the graphics side
in terms of raw gpu power and 3d mark
wildlife extreme the ultra got around 45
more fps which honestly isn't too bad
for spending 1100 more but going into
some real world stuff like the blender
bmw cycles render it was only 20 faster
which i honestly don't think is worth
the extra 31 cash because you're also
sacrificing portability with the mac
studio but the absolute worst results
that we found were in terms of video
editing where exporting common h.264 and
h.265 videos led to basically no gains
at all because apparently the extra set
of media engines in the ultra cannot be
utilized at all right now and in terms
of playback smoothness the 24 core m1
max yeah not the 32 core already can run
15 streams of 4k hevc footage with extra
effects without dropping frames and we
even stacked a huge amount of effects
color corrections luts masks and
animated titles on a single stream of
heavier canon r5 footage and it didn't
drop any frames showing that almost
nobody will be able to get extra
playback smoothness from the m1 ultra so
because of that we decided to export 8k
red raw which doesn't support encoders
and decoders and the m1 ultramax studio
was only 14
faster definitely not worth the extra
1100
it was only when we exported a five
minute 4k pro res raw video to prores
that we finally started seeing the
encoders and decoders being used
properly giving us a 33
improvement and then in our final 8k
canon raw to 4k hvc torture test the m1
ultra was only 22 faster than the
macbook pro which is just so
disappointing compared to our initial
expectations now if you're wondering why
the ultra isn't performing that well
it's because the gpu has a major
hardware bottleneck that limits the top
end performance of the gpu and slows
everything down and unfortunately this
isn't going to change until apps get
optimized or until apple releases the m2
ultra with a fix for the hardware issue
so with all that said i would honestly
say that the m1 ultra isn't worth it for
the majority of people out there and
because of that the m1 max macbook pro
just leveled up in terms of how much
value i think it has and i'm so happy i
made this purchase around six months ago
especially since i've been enjoying so
many of its other features so hopefully
you guys enjoyed my six month review of
the 16 inch macbook pro and if you did
go ahead and click the circle about to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and definitely check out one of those
two right over there including our other
comparisons thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]